[Applauso]
buonasera
in sostanza una tragedia
cioè decimo dopo due video 9 relatori
per giunta dopo michelangelo un
banchiere c'è proprio tragedia e per
giunta
io avevo immaginato di raccontarvi
qualcosa come 4 150 anni di storia in
sei minuti e lo faccio davvero però lo
faccio cercando di non annoiare che
conosce già tutto per affrontare un tema
che il tutto l'entusiasmo l'ottimismo
questa sera in realtà risvolto
emozionale dell'innovazione
sull'imprenditore sull'impresa sul
lavoro noi oggi abbiamo e l'abbiamo
sentito dagli altri relatori la
percezione di essere in una
discontinuità portata dell'innovazione
dove quasi tutta la nostra tradizione
viene messa in discussione le cose che
facciamo i lavori che facciamo
e in effetti è una situazione molto
simile a quella della rivoluzione
industriale più volte citata allora le
macchine l'introduzione motore a scoppio
automatizzando le la forza delle braccia
o moltiplicandolo di nuovo mise in
discussione tutto tutte le imprese
preindustriali modelli di impresa sono
spariti tutti quei lavori fate conto
l'agricoltura in europa eravamo 140
milioni
oggi siamo 700 800 seconda del perimetro
il 70 per cento degli occupati era in
agricoltura
eliminazione strutturale del 90 per
cento lavora in agricoltura oggi il 3
per cento di 700 milioni
eppure tutti noi ricordiamo rivoluzione
industriale per la leggiamo secoli dopo
con un risvolto positivo perché allora
sappiamo che l'aspettativa di vita era
di circa poco più di 30 anni
l'analfabetismo era volta nel 95 per
cento
la salute era una cosa assai precaria si
moriva per un taglio
l'epidemia errore del giorno la
popolazione non cresceva
la povertà era lo stato sociale più
diffuso fatto in quel mondo che non
conosceva la democrazia non si premiava
il merito neppure la libertà individuale
c'era eppure allora vedevamo quello come
la messa in discussione della tradizione
oggi è molto simile
oggi prima la scienza dell'informazione
e poi le reti oggi l'intelligenza
artificiale automatizzano un altro
fattore umano fondamentale che il
cervello o meglio ne ampliano la portata
e sappiamo che tutti i lavori che
facciamo oggi in parte spariranno e
quindi chi fa il mio mestiere ma credo
anche chi fa che ha un negozio di fatto
fronteggia giornalmente questa cosa come
ci si comporta di fronte a questo ed
appaiono no la risposta però dai 450
anni di storia che adesso sinteticamente
racconto
vorrei trarre alcuni spunti la storia
evidentemente molti la conoscono
cercherò di dare un film diverso è
quello della famiglia a quello fortuna
di appartenere che inizia nel 1570
l'attività imprenditoriale e qui la
prima fotografia 14 generazioni di
imprenditori che arrivano ad oggi oggi
si dà lavoro a 6.000 persone
direttamente a tante chissà quante altre
indirettamente e 1570 non esisteva anche
la parola l'imprenditore era un mondo
agricolo monarchico nobiliare il regno
di savoia non c'era la parola non c'era
l'intrapresa tant'è che si sviluppa di
fatto se sella è una frazione della
valle qui dietro 750 metri di quota un
posto di pecore castagna e
sostanzialmente e l'attività tessile da
cui iniziamo è un'attività agricola
perché le pecore c'era qualche gregge
maggiore ma ciascuno ne aveva un po i
telai erano di legno a mano in ogni casa
veniva ha fatto il tessuto la sera dopo
una certa ora specie nelle sere di
inverno e quindi l'imprenditore tessile
era qualcosa di molto diverso sia molto
agricola come attività si raccoglievano
le pezze talvolta si tingevano poi si
commerciavano
e l'innovazione e qualcuno conosce sa
che facciamo il vino da dove nasce 1670
diventiamo produttori di vino perché
1670 che cosa usavamo come moneta di
scambio nel 1670 erano pietre oro
argento rame
la moneta era fatta di quella materiali
ma il regno di savoia non aveva miniere
neppure faceva commerci quindi non c'era
draghi col quanto divisi in two da
imprenditore di parte il business non
c'è la materia prima non sono i soldi
allora in allora si incomincia a
produrre vino per dare per comprarle
pezzi e o per dare agli operai
direttamente ciò che loro avrebbero
comprato con i soldi che mancavano per
pagare
oggi si parla di bitcoin non è cambiato
la rivoluzione industriale 1815
mettetevi nei tempi di allora lo statuto
albertino e del 48 la libertà
individuale era appena passato napoleone
restaurazione prezzi delle materie prime
bassi per una serie di fenomeni
economici dovuti al protezionismo in più
sfortuna vuole che la produzione anni di
carestia crisi totale
la rivoluzione striale che noi oggi
ricordiamo tutto benessere che ci dà in
allora la crisi totale prodotti inglesi
di qualità maggiore messi sul mercato e
lì cosa si fa ci si mette a si viaggia
si va a vedere se si mette a fare
l'operaio un anno manchester il sella di
allora torna indietro dopo un anno aver
imparato non tanto la macchina perché
intuitivo come il telaio a mano diventa
un telaio meccanico ma è la fabbrica
quel mondo rurale in cui si viveva tutti
qui che dava da mangiare a tutti diventa
una scatola e non siamo ancora al terzo
al ritorno del paradiso siamo nel bel
mezzo di quel fenomeno che il maestro
descriveva e comprate la macchina
portati qui due anni per montarla perché
gli operai vano paura che la macchina
portasse via il lavoro e il re aveva
paura che gli operai arrabbiati
mettessero in crisi la fragile stabilità
del regno due anni per avere il permesso
ma non basta perché
noi non abbiamo il carbone e le macchine
vanno a carbone e qui ci vuole un'altra
decina d'anni per intuire che bisogna
avere una ruota per fare usare l'acqua
come forza motrice
ma noi non abbiamo l'energia
metallurgica quindi la ruota si compra
di nuovo in belgio e arriva in italia
montata immaginate tutta la francia da
fare i paesini da girare intorno al
centro per la ruota non passava pensate
a passare il gran san bernardo a dorso
di mulo passare alla fine novembre
però quella ruota si dice nel biellese a
partire dall'acqua e ciò che fa nascere
oggi il distretto tessile dellese la
ruota che inizia a girare ma non basta
mica perché subito dopo arriva la
chimica e qui sella di allora va a
studiare a parigi gay lussac incomincia
prime formule i sali e gli al khali ma
non è che basta conoscerla teoria
bisogna applicarla e qui un laboratorio
cinque anni gli costò anche la salute
per decodificare delle formule oggi la
chiameremo algoritmi in un qualcosa di
traducibile in un processo industriale
riuscito il quale però trasforma questo
dove siamo noi oggi nel più grande
lanificio del regno d'italia di allora
ma anche lì le cose cambiano e e
l'economia comincia a svilupparsi e
allora le famose pietre di prima quelle
che usavamo come moneta di scambio
le monete nel 1861 quando c'erano tali
tagli al 5 per cento circolante carta
l'invenzione la cartamoneta è uno degli
elementi fondamentali ma cosa succede
fino ad allora chi risparmiasse se voi
risparmia mate delle pietre le pietre
restavano lì quindi le toglieva the
dalla circolazione oggi noi siamo
abituati a pensare al risparmio come
stimolo allora il risparmio deprimeva
l'economia perché toglieva dalla
circolazione e quella poca unità di
valore che c'era allora l'intuizione che
in realtà quello che oggi chiamiamo
banca raccontino che va il problema a
livello nazionale di fare in modo che il
risparmio diventasse un attività
produttiva ed ecco quindi nascere il
dovere di usare il risparmio per
produrre qualche cosa e quindi usare il
proprio patrimonio a fronte dei rischi
della far circolare il risparmio e nasce
la banca qui insomma il tempo è limitato
per per raccontarla tutta ma sono due o
tre passaggi che voglio raccontare uno
negli anni 80 la banca incomincia
a dimostrarsi inefficace per far
funzionare alcune cose e nel mondo si
affermano a crescono i mercati
finanziari
allora tu sei in banca e capisci che se
il risparmio va verso i mercati non
viene verso di te se va verso i mercati
la tua attività viene messa in
discussione
e tu guadagni di meno però evidente che
l'innovazione è vantaggiosa vantaggiosa
per il cliente che può investire che può
nascere la scelta immediatamente diventa
quella di consigliare alla clientela
l'investimento più produttivo che
quell'altro non è necessariamente quello
dell'attività di banca o negli anni 95 e
da lì nasce l'eccellenza nella gestione
risparmio negli anni 95 96 con internet
io quando iniziato in banca facevo il
cassiere e il nostro obiettivo a far
avvenire la gente in filiale qui arriva
internet che chiaramente ti consente di
fare in modo cioè consente al cliente di
non venire più è immediatamente fa
scendere si intuisce che fa scendere il
prezzo i ricavi e anche lì la scelta
immediata fu di sposarla subito con dei
benefici quando nel 2012 2011 abbiamo
incominciato a comprendere le cose che
avete sentito nei due video c'è che
l'impresa preesistente
non è più il luogo ideale per far
nascere innovazione e l'open innovation
la guida anche qui creiamo se la lab e
cerchiamo di adottare qualche cosa che
mette in discussione il tuo modello
perché dai fuori aprì la capacità di
innovazione
se volete oggi il prodotto che sta
tirando di più della banca che più o
meno ha fatto in due anni e un lo stesso
numero di clienti e che un quinto dei
clienti che il resto il gruppo ha fatto
in 130 nasce in realtà da fuori da una
collaborazione completamente diversa
allora in pochissimo tempo 450 anni di
storia
che cosa secondo me aiutano a vedere sul
tema che io voglio affrontare che è
quello di come si maneggia l'effetto di
questa innovazione è il senso di timore
che in una discontinuità si sente
raccontare tutto il giorno del primo è
che ste discontinuità se la guardate nei
secoli sono del tutto normale è solo più
più più frequente la portata del
cambiamento
la seconda cosa che rileva è che
l'innovazione è costante nel tempo e
rinnovata tutto lo sviluppo
tutto ciò che abbiamo il figlio
dell'innovazione e la terza cosa che si
legge guardandola nell'insieme che era
tale innovazione non è casuale risolve
dei bisogni migliore delle cose quindi è
un flusso costante non è negativa quindi
se questo è vero che se questo lo legge
lo leggete anche voi in questa sintesi
allora quando torni a mettere cappello
dell'imprenditore o di chi ha un lavoro
che deve prendere scelte di vita del
primo il primo concetto che io ne traggo
e innovare innovare sempre se ci pensate
non c'è tradizione
l'unica cosa della tradizione perlomeno
dal punto di vista produttivo non c'è
nulla della nostra tradizione
dal punto di vista pratico che ci sia
l'unica cosa che rimasta l'innovazione
quella costante secondo elemento è sì
sofistica un pochettino è che quando
l'innovazione è utile risolve un bisogno
va adottata sempre anche se contro il
tuo interesse
apparentemente quello che viene
denominato la disruption in realtà è
molto meglio fare in proprio la
disruption di se stessi che vederla fare
un terzo
anche perché tu capitalizzi tutta
l'esperienza che hai messo in campo in
quella che in realtà è la tua mission ea
è un vantaggio straordinario di
credibilità
il terzo elemento è che questa
innovazione non son riuscito a
trasmetterlo perché ho sondato rapido
mai data si alimenta nella tradizione o
meglio quella parte intangibile della
tradizione che è l'esperienza che la
conoscenza che è l'ispirazione noi lo
vediamo qui nel nostro acceleratore
vediamo che le iniziative di maggior
successo sono quelle dove chi ha spinta
giovane vede ha un'ambizione viene messo
a fianco di un mentore di qualcuno che
gli porta la propria esperienza
precedente che viene ascoltata fino a un
certo punto ma è fonte d'ispirazione
anche e soprattutto nelle difficoltà
quando vi mettete dall'altro lato volete
innovare e le difficoltà arrivano presto
ma vera essere a fianco a qualcuno che è
riuscito in quello alla fonte
d'ispirazione straordinaria e qui si
arriva
ma cosa c'è dietro alla fine siamo né
gli intangibili la tradizione che cos'è
la cosa ed è il messaggio principale che
che io leggo da tutta questa storia in
realtà la tradizione e lo sviluppo della
conoscenza e oserei dire della coscienza
è un mix di valori e ispirazioni ed è lì
che incomincia a realizzare che in
realtà l'obiettivo di fare qualcosa di
meglio gli ideali di ispirazioni che
sono figlie della tradizione sono il
motore principale dell'innovazione
non sono nessuno il motore ma solo la
condizione perché l'innovazione abbia
successo perché sia utile io non ho mai
osservato un'innovazione che non abbia
un obiettivo positivo che non segua
determinati valori giungere al successo
e se questa innovazione davvero riesce a
portare un miglioramento riesce a
portare essere un progresso nella
coscienza e nei valori
ecco che le famose ricadute ci sono e da
lì che nasce la fertilizzazione per il
nuovo cosa intendo dove sono andati a
lavorare quelle 67 per cento di
popolazione che lavorava in agricoltura
non l'avremmo mai immaginato in allora
ci avessero chiesto ad immaginarlo ma
sono quell'insieme di attività che sono
nate dallo sviluppo delle passioni della
risoluzione dei bisogni innalzando via
via i nostre ambizioni e ideali e
progressi e quindi diventa una
condizione intrinseca allo sviluppo
della conoscenza dei valori l'abbiamo
sentito in più di un intervento del
contributo che i valori danno alle
successo allora ad esempio noi abbiamo
deciso di tenere qui i nostri centri di
innovazione abbiamo di tenerli qui per
due motivi uno perché le pietre di
questo lanificio del 1832 dicono che
l'innovazione necessaria ma dall'altro
lato dicono che l'innovazione si
trasforma nel tempo è qualcosa di
positivo
se porta avanti dei valori positivi e
quindi la mia conclusione di fatto
tornando al dilemma di chi deve prendere
delle decisioni e maneggiare molto
astratta me ne rendo conto però è il
motore principale che ci muove è di non
vedere l'innovazione con una minaccia
non vederla per i suoi risvolti negativi
perché in realtà non lo è
ma di vederla come una grande
opportunità che abbiamo la fortuna di
vivere per fare tutto quello che i
nostri padri e genitori avrebbero sempre
sognato di fare e sempre oggi è sempre
più facile questo e la passione con cui
noi lo facciamo gli ideali che ci
guidano ei valori che portiamo avanti
sono di fatto il motore di tutto questo
l'uomo esploratore l'uomo anela qualcosa
di meglio è chiaro che a un insieme di
freni e di reazione al cambiamento di
aree di confort che vuole preservare ma
esploratore nel profondo periodo come
questo in cui l'innovazione l'abbiamo
sentito da francesca e tutti gli altri
interventi ci consente di fare le cose
in realtà straordinario quindi
l'approccio è di con umiltà esplorazione
passione valori e ideali di cercare di
costruire qualcosa di positivo per il
nostro futuro come modalità per
maneggiare l'innovazione grazie
[Applauso]